we don't know the fate of your character  yet but should we be worried is there a  chance that your character could be the  one floating in the ocean well you  should be worried because you know he's  a bit of a dog what do I know oh yeah I  would be worried maybe who knows with  Mike's writing you never No One Is Safe  there was a thought in my mind to just  like say and spoil the whole thing wow  if you had the choice yourself to be in  season three of White Lotus no matter  what it is would you do it yes  oh my god of course I would pass out  water on the third season it depends on  if I'm you know like a fan favorite I  think it just you know depends on what  who people want you are a fan favorite  they want me but I have no idea the gays  Love Jennifer the way they love you okay  we love you okay okay see you next  season